bon alors maintenant je vais te faire un
questionnaire d'enfer spécial pour toi
non je te jure
c'est quoi
c'est très gentil première question mais
vraiment la question qu'on tient est-ce
que tu préfères ton père ou ta mère
on ne peut pas répondre deuxièmement
deuxième question celle-là tu vas tu
pourras pas dire les deux est-ce que tu
préfères vivre 10 ans très très très
riche vraiment avec tout ce que tu veux
j'ai des 747 voilà ou alors sans tampon
est-ce que tu serais prête à mourir là
maintenant ta tumeur avant la première
s'il te plaît juste après
juste après la première tumeur pour que
un million de petits éthiopiens puissent
survivre
imagine tu as plus de pognon tu as plus
rien à leur donner à manger ils sont
vraiment je vais les perdre dans la
forêt non
c'est pauvre enfant pour les pour qu'ils
puissent manger est-ce que tu es vende
de la drogue à la sortie des écoles
aux autres
est-ce que tu le ferais ça c'est la
question qu'on parle excellence
pour qui à qui trouves-tu le plus de
circonstances atténuantes
Staline Hitler ou Paul pot
entiel
c'est quand même du
[Musique]
dictateurs
lequel tu excuses le plus des trois
stalines Hitler ou Paul Paul
qui sont bizarres à la limite quoi
je considère pas que leur gouvernement
bon alors je continue quelle race
préfères-tu les jaunes les blancs les
noirs ou les rouges
qu'est-ce que tu préfères vrai être
sourde muette aveugle première solution
ou alors avoir les quatre membres coupés
à ras moi je la préférée
aveugle première solution deuxième
solution les quatre membres tu peux
quand même regarder la télé tu peux
regarder
Sabatier
écoute je sais pas là tu vois je veux
dire j'aimerais autant comme on verra
il sera toujours dans le sens
tout seul dans un refuge de montagne
perdu à huit jours de marche de de du
premier être vivant et puis tu as envie
de faire l'amour parce que ça fait un
mois que tu es dans ce refuge
et alors imagine bien à ce moment-là
qu'est-ce que tu préfères vrai faire
l'amour avec une femme une personne du
même sexe que toi
ou alors je te masturber
ah oui c'est comment
[Musique]
la suite si tu devais vraiment toujours
pas été dans le refuge tu es avec un
très bon ami cette fois et il meurt deux
fois est-ce que tu commencerais
est-ce que tu commencerais par manger le
doigt ou les joues jambon
[Musique]
ah oui d'accord je suis son mari cher
monsieur je peux vous dire que c'est pas
facile et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez
un pouce bleu